one good morning Westeros welcome to the
number one morning morning show in all
of the Seven Kingdoms it is the toast I
am your co-host Jamin Targaryen good
morrow brother good Mara brother I'm
your co-host the saris the peaceful what
an honor to be sitting down with the
King on my number one morning show the
toast Damon making it himself we built
it together as brothers uh you are a
little busy I cannot do this you were a
little busy losing all your fingers to
be building an empire like I am don't be
jealous cause I'm a mogul and you're
simply a king you were a little busy
murdering your wife taking on a terrible
[ __ ] and engaging in incest yes to be
running a business brother that's why
you'll never be a truly great king
incest is best we all know that we all
and that's why it'll never be a truly
great brother
Fair Point welcome guys to toaster
Wheaton
2022.
Jackie and I are here not as Jackson
Claude Jackson Claude actually been
working so hard they took the day off
they took the day off and our good
friends Damon and viserys Targaryen
decided to join us today for toastoween
if you watch House of the Dragon then
you know and if you don't want to watch
House of the Dragon now would be a great
time to start now would be a great time
to start and if you've been listening to
all our Recaps this whole time like you
know under Cyrus the king the peaceful
like not a great man but not a bad one
and then we have Damon jury's still out
Troublemaker widow's peak
lover of nieces and that's a lever
that's appropriate because one thing
here at the toast is like we really
value aunts and uncles the stress
Brethren are our dragons and they are
eating their wings oh [ __ ] they have
resorted to eating their wings they've
been in their dragon costumes for like
an hour now yeah but first everyone has
to see the dragons of Westeros oh my God
Theo's literally chewing on his way he's
got a clipped wing
he's a Wily Dragon this is sorex
and Anthrax this is thorax and rice ax
thorax and Bryce hacks These Wings Are
actually really cute costume ideas but
like the boys are hating them but it's
like all hour they've been waiting for
us to take them off and now they know if
they start chewing them we'll have to
take them we also we did a photo shoot
with them this morning so like they've
done their due diligence and we can set
them free okay we're setting free the
dragons they're truly The Wind Beneath
My Wings there you go Theo there you go
Bryce
Prosper these are really cute though
yeah they're like pretty Chic excuse me
feels like no put them back on I like to
Theo stop you'll eat it oh God the
clipped away and you'll eat it and
you'll like it
um so good morning everyone hope
everyone had an absolutely splint
Splendid Halloween weekend seven
blessings to us all seven blessings
throughout the Seven Kingdoms
um
I was slightly dreading this episode
because for some reason whenever I talk
in a British accent I immediately become
Russian and Jamaican and that's not the
plan you know no it's not the plan and
whenever I talk in British action I
immediately become brother you
immediately become like very Rowdy
where's Granger Harris Cran joharis
um yeah whenever I dress in opposite sex
like something takes over something
takes over it's like Ben being Aina yeah
Ben dressed as Aina yesterday Ina Garten
and he immediately started acting
different yeah he looks so funny funny I
couldn't even look at him no it was
actually jarring to see him looking so
feminine like he actually like looked
pretty but the pictures of the two of
you together you were Jeffrey he was
just it was too much it was far too much
it was too much for a kid's neighborhood
Halloween party no I agree especially we
showed up to the Halloween party um in
Jackie's neighborhood and like we
thought you know all the adults would be
dressed as a Halloween party right it's
a costume party and literally none of
the adults were dressed now I know it's
hard to kids it's hard to get out the
door with all your kids in costumes like
I have I have you know understanding for
the moms and the dads but like come on
it's Halloween yeah so we just like felt
really stupid walking around in my crazy
Albert Einstein wig yeah walking around
like in my huge Priscilla wig and heels
yeah no we were like the big adult dopes
yeah but at least we have each other you
know right at least we had fun always
not as fun as toaster weed in 2022.
sickening content for our Instagram
already so that's why I'm personally out
of breath yeah and why we've already
given it all to being Miss Harris and
Naaman so what does it mean to you to be
king brother thank you for asking I
think like most great Kings
were good you know decent Kings it's not
something that I ever really
wanted too badly right now that the
responsibility has been bestowed upon me
I take it with the utmost seriousness no
of course honestly I kind of cannot
believe that my podcast landed an
interview with the King after so much
fanfare
um why don't you tell us exclusively who
you meant to your final message for yeah
no I didn't stutter I meant for Rainier
um obviously Allison heard what you
wanted to hear yeah like literally I'm
not well why are you listening to me I'm
making no sense right and you're gonna
wage war over the nonsense I just spewed
and brother honestly you should have
taken a page out of my book and just
killed her
she's a nice girl you know she just is
mixed up with the wrong crowd the wrong
seven the wrong fam the wrong Fam I'm
gonna try and do a British accent as
much as I can but honestly it's
extremely difficult it is I need to
She's mixed up with the wrong fam fam
that was really good
um it is just a mean but of course we've
got a fabulous show for you guys today
fast five stories lots to discuss
um
you might be confused because you're
probably like Claudia
your dress is Damon Targaryen you look
like Ava Max
the good news is and here's why the good
news is we are recording a vlog yes
Halloween weekend at my house like
getting dressed for yesterday getting
dressed for toasting it's honestly so
funny and I did give Claudia an alive
haircut on the Vlog so you'll see it all
and you gave it really like zero percent
of your attention I I didn't realize how
much attention it required and for that
I apologize she just went at it on one
half with the scissors and now I'm Ava
Max it's not real hair I'm the biggest
pop star in Westeros like I mean that
ain't that the truth oh she's sweet but
a psycho a little bit
I understand the Ava Max look like I'm
kind of feeling it not for this costume
but just like in general no I've
understood it for a while because it's
like every pop Star has done something
you know we have two-toned hair we have
a meat dress like how are you gonna
stand apart How You Gonna top that I'll
have two different length hairs no and
it's like depending on what angle I take
a picture from either I have like a cute
mid haircut or a full-on bob a choppy
Bob but and probably Ava loves The
Duality duality of both I I would
imagine brother I honestly would get you
a girl who could do both get you a girl
who can do both so have a weekend my
weekend was great it was the same as
your weekend we had a great weekend full
of Halloween we didn't make our special
cookies and I we're running out of time
I know we are headed back actually
Jackie's coming to New York with me when
I return this week so the last couple of
episodes
um this week will be in New York studio
with Jax which is so exciting so
exciting and in less than a week is my
30th birthday I don't want to bring it
up I gotta know a few like I'm embracing
it you're embracing it yeah I'm excited
it's another like I mean your hair is
turning gray already it doesn't have
like birthdays like who said they have
to get sad as you get older like it's
still a day about you and especially as
you get older less days are about you
that's true especially when you have
kids I look forward to seeing like how
everyone plans to celebrate me no and
you still get presents and and like when
you're the people in your life are older
more financially like secure value
better they get better and also like I
love to get myself a present so that's
exciting too right and I'm working on
that you're working on that yeah I
haven't secured what I wanted but um I
do want to do you have an idea of what
you want yeah I want a new Crown I think
this one's a little rusty yeah yeah how
about Steve maybe you need a new Throne
I can sit on the one you're currently
sitting on I'm sure I love that Damian
but let's be real like you're an amazing
brother you're such you're too good of
an uncle a hundred percent Rainier loves
you too much that Rainier and she's a
good girl you know you're a good time
like I would love to hit the clubs with
you would love to hit the brothels and I
mean this we know sincerity as your Boba
who is I think everyone can say like
viserys is a logical King yeah literally
I don't know if everyone would say that
um you would not make a good King
you were not you have a tendency towards
the extremes you
would let the power go to your head you
would you would and I think your
strengths lie in other Pursuits brev rev
we've literally discussed this in family
counseling so many times and I don't
personally appreciate you coming on my
podcast that I have built from the
ground up after I was with my name after
I was canceled in 25 BC I think it's
really disgusting of you to come on here
insult me on my show and honestly I
think it's best if you just leave listen
brev let's get real once again you're
writing my coattails nobody would care
about your podcast if your above wasn't
the king oh please do you see this
hairline do you know what women in
Westeros would do to be Mrs Damon
Targaryen they would kill they would die
they would kill to be my lady to lay in
my bed they would die to be here do you
know what women would do they would
sooner die than lay in your bed and
change your bed pants you old hag at
least I have women changing my bed pens
Damon talk to me when you're old and
gray you know what I have already gray
you know what I have
your daughter changing my bedpans let's
not get nasty let's not get enough says
the king says the king with no fingers
let's not get nasty don't bring the
daughter into this
let's talk about the husband
you don't want to go there you Beast
um
so yeah like Eastern Westeros is
actually like a flattering term like we
have these beastly dragons no I mean I
guess it depends who you are if you're
like a woman living in Westeros I don't
think you want to be called abuse no but
are we women in Westeros no oh right
right the king and the spare you should
quit the royal family right write a book
bear oh my God does that make Megan
Rainier no it's not totally analogous no
it's not but maybe I will write it demon
does give Harry energy because it's that
spare energy where it's a constantly
being overlooked it's a lifetime of
being overlooked yeah but Damon
I again like I seated I think he's
really successful in other Pursuits like
what you did in this in the sandstones
so true topped off Damon you should be
so proud I am I honestly am and I have a
beautiful beautiful sexy wife whom you
know has oh
[Laughter]
I have a beautiful you heard what you
said about it I have a beautiful wife
really stunning wife she Bears my
children She lays with me I'm so blessed
to have such a wonderful gorgeous sexy
niece slash wife listen brav
I'd never been anything but kind to you
uh so you didn't tell me about The Song
of Ice and Fire but you did not tell me
about the song yeah you're the smell
well I was the yeah I was the experience
for 30 years does that mean nothing to
you it's very Vibes I was the spare and
I heard nothing about the song
jealous
are we yes we have this like little
secret us in line it's a song that we'll
sing sing it bruv
[Music]
I literally knew you were gonna do that
too it's a story of the prince he was a
prince who was promised and there's
gonna be a war we're fighting in the
north because this is it is the song of
this A Song of Ice and Fire ice and fire
it's a song fit for a prince before
Prince but nobody knows the prince will
be because Allison is a dumb hoe and yes
she is a big jumper I was lying on death
row this is the song that never pop up
get Otto out of my bed Chambers this is
a song The Prince will sing when song is
ice and fire oh we're fighting with the
North and there will be a great pirate
this is a song I personally love when
there's a great pie the thing about the
king is like everyone's Justice king of
course of course but I have so many
other things that I want to pursue
acting acting singing like I love to
draw I like to make my little sand
castle in my room yeah you love a good
Lego I love Legos and people just see
King King King what can we get from King
but what about what king wants what
about what king feels brother nobody
cares it's not about you season two
you're not you're just a king you're
just a king I'm just a king and life is
a nightmare British people like must be
watching it's like vomiting no I don't I
I think they feel really good about it
our accents yeah because these aren't
British accents they're West Rose said
where the [ __ ] is that that's what me
and Ben were talking about last night
because before I fell asleep I was like
you know going on about I was nervous
about my British accent he's like well
it's not even British because this right
now is not a terrible British accent and
I don't sound like anyone from House of
the Dragon yeah no Westeros they never
tell us like where it is in real life
but like if you think about history like
it's somewhere in Europe so yeah we're
not offending anyone in particular no I
mean I was gonna try and be the [ __ ]
but I couldn't Master her accent neither
could she
um so should we dive in we've got a
great show like lots to discuss we do a
lot of Halloween news from celebs this
weekend I want to talk about their
costumes and I have something to say
about celebrity Halloween costumes so
like we really don't care not even that
um maybe it's like a cell phone to say
this but like I have no idea who these
people are who they're dressing up as
they're dressing up as yeah like all
these Kylie costumes like no it's like
we've gone to a place in Halloween where
people are just finding really really
Niche pop culture references whether
it's like from movies music and like
just make recreating the exact photo
right well the thing about like the
photo it's like did you even go anywhere
did you do anything in that costume how
did you move around it they didn't but
also like I'm just gonna be honest and
say like I don't know what a lot of
these things movies characters are no
like Haley Bieber looked so stunning
should this whole photo shoot she was
wearing a dress made out of flowers and
like the costume she said in her caption
was like inspired by like you know
vintage YSL that's not a costume wear
that to the Met Gala right but no that
that's not even like I'm really sorry
like Kylie's first costumer she's like
brighter Frankenstein that's what that
is I believe I don't know and then the
second costume Elvira I think was what's
happening I don't know I have no [ __ ]
clue maybe because I don't watch
Halloween horror movies but I see I
think of this all the time like unless
you're being something so obvious
if you're a niche character I'm like I
have no idea what you are no but then
like the obvious ones
um everyone does them it's actually
really really hard
whether you're a celebrity or a
layperson to like do a really good
original costume these days yeah it's
like they've all been thought of
yeah but it's like why are we putting
this pressure on ourselves like no go
get a Spirit Halloween put it on and go
have fun I do feel like this year was
like tame in comparison to previous
years where people like were just going
so insane photo shoot like four nights
in a row yeah I feel like there was one
night this year it was Saturday night
because Halloween's on a Monday and for
the most part like people were doing one
maybe two costumes but like there was a
while where people were spending like so
much time energy money on like these
elaborate costumes photo shoots just to
like do it in their house yeah for some
Instagram likes yeah but I don't like
look forward to people's costumes in the
way that I look forward to like people's
outfits at the Met Gala or like certain
things every year Halloween is not one
of those things it just feels like a lot
of times when you take some perspective
you take a step back Big Bang you're
like oh everyone looks like a clown
Beyond I mean look at us I mean amazing
it's also important to mention like this
conversation does not pertain to us
brother not at all whatsoever like no at
all
got our costumes from Spirit well not
these ones but like yesterday we were
like normal Halloween people got your
costume from Spirit like worked with
what you had in the house yeah I think
like I wore a wig that I got on Amazon
and wore a dress of my own yeah and it
was Halloween I did my own makeup I
don't have to have a makeup artist I
don't know if that's us getting older or
Halloween just like changing
I think it's I don't think Halloween's
changed I think it's people in the
culture especially with Instagram and
Tick Tock because now you need the tick
tock video of you saying what the
character said and if you didn't take it
then then why did you dress up oh I have
a good Tick Tock for us to make up what
are we gonna say there's a scene from an
interview with Allison
excuse me Allison and uh raniera that's
gone viral what's your drink of choice
Negroni oh
that's an interview with that Prosecco
in it I heard I know the sound it's
Alison and it's grown up Allison and
grown up Rainier when they like wanted
us to learn more about the girls who
were playing the new older characters
they did like these series of interviews
and that little clip went viral so we'll
do it okay cool yeah sweet so now
without further Ado yeah do the strikes
brothers are here they've been the most
amazing dragons amazing amazing like
dracars on these hoes [ __ ]
it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know
today's episode is sponsored by Honey
the easy way to save When shopping on
your iPhone or computer thanks to Honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past honey is the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best one
it finds to your cart here's how it
works imagine you're shopping on one of
your favorite websites when you check
out the honey button will appear and all
you have to do is Click apply coupons
wait a few seconds as honey searches for
coupons it can find for that website and
if honey finds a working coupon you'll
watch the price drop so we've used honey
for years I got my sword on honey I've
got my bed pans on honey I've got your
crown obviously came from honey of
course
um I've saved money honestly on like
makeup Electronics food pretty much
everything most of the places I online
shop at work with honey and it's really
nice because you don't have to do
anything you just like this little
you'll forget you downloaded the browser
extension and this little man will pop
up be like hey girl it's like a little
gold coin want to save some money and
the gold coin has legs we love gold
coins in Western I love the Lannister
Always Pays his debts so you just click
it boom you like revolve most of the
places I shop work with it and it really
is fabulous and now something new I just
found out is that it doesn't just work
on your desktop anymore it also works on
your iPhone you just have to activate it
on Safari on your phone and you'll be
saving on the go so if you don't already
have honey then you are straight up
missing out by getting it you're doing
yourself a solid we'd never recommend
something we don't use we've been using
honey for years the toaster's actually
told us about it long before honey was a
sponsor you can get honey for free when
you go to joinhoney.com toast that's
join honey
j-o-i-n-h-o-n-e-y.com slash toast
joinhoney.com you guessed it toast
t-o-a-s-t today's episode is also
sponsored by Legacy box
the world is getting crazy Stakes are
always getting higher
big days are ahead but wouldn't it be
nice to go back to the good old days
well Legacy box is the simplest and
safest way to digitize all of your aging
videotapes camcorder tapes film reels
and pictures so they are preserved
forever so I have to say I have all the
sponsors on the show I get the most DMS
about Legacy box like when we haven't
done a read for them in like a couple
days people are like what was that name
of that company what was the code Legacy
box is the best way to take we grew up
in the VHS era but whatever old Like
Home Videos you have sitting in a
basement they digitize it all for you
they do it really safely really securely
and in a timely fashion and is such a
good gift to get for someone especially
with the holidays coming up first of all
because you're clearing them of all this
storage like you're gonna give them
their basement back because all these
boxes of tapes are going to be gone and
you're giving them Memories Back which
is so special we did it a few years ago
because we were like had boxes and boxes
of VHS in our house and it is such a
delightful experience
because we used to spend like hundreds
of dollars on these like VHS reader
things and it just it never worked so um
we were able to get back some iconic
home videos of us singing the Spice
Girls obviously you know one of us
really kind of stuck out as a star with
like a potentially really good singing
voice thank you that's really sweet it
was me and I was really incredible so
Legacy box is really easy
um they do it all for you so they
personally digitize it in the US if you
have it they can digitize it everything
from VHS tapes to photos to Super 8 film
reels
um each kit includes everything that you
need to safely pack and send your
recorded moments so once you use our
code they'll send you all the packaging
materials you put it in the Box they
give you the label and they really do it
all for you it truly couldn't be easier
digitize your memories with Legacy box
grab some popcorn gather the family to
revisit the good old days Plus for a
limited time they're offering a special
sale Legacy box is offering our
listeners an exclusive offer when you go
to legacybox.com toast to shop this
incredible deal that's legacybox.com
toast it is a special special election
sale big days coming up let's revert to
the past with legacybox.com toast
legacybox.com toast our first story the
best Halloween costumes of celebrities
of 2022. so far
according to page six I'm curious to
know what you thought was the best
costume okay first we have lizzo is
Marge Simpson I thought it was okay yeah
that's cool yeah it's a lot of work um I
thought her other costume she's very
like on the pulse of Pop Culture I wanna
kill my mom this kid who went viral on
Tick Tock for like saying something
crazy he um she dressed up as him in
another costume I thought that one was
better yeah like did she go to a party
dressed as Mark Simpson I don't know but
like the yellow paint like was giving me
anxiety like like if you're getting an
Uber you're finished 250 fine easily
Lily Reinhardt Madeleine petting Cami
Mendes as the Sanderson sisters from
Hocus Pocus this was great idea great
execution great execution I think the
Sanders and sisters has become like kind
of like a corny like Halloween costume
that everyone does but it's back again
because it's the sequel It's back and if
you're gonna do it at this level of like
Glam costume makeup and one of them is
truly a redhead one is truly brunette
and one is truly blonde it was very well
executed love it love it one of my
favorites actually it was really well
done party like this yes they they made
also like amazing tick tocks and stuff
it was good I didn't even see those and
I still liked it next Diddy as the Joker
he was in like all of Kim's stories
where did they go they went to tree she
went to Tracy Alice's Ellis Ross's
birthday party oh and she didn't know it
was not a costume party and she showed
up in her blue X-Men outfit as Mystique
from X-Men I thought she was Avatar so I
thought you that's what I mean I thought
she was Avatar too like and then she
posted with Natalie and Olivia and I'm
like oh so you were Avatar and then they
were something else yeah and they all
had names and I was like and I don't
know who any of them are and that's on
me this is a cell phone like I don't
know Marvel characters I don't know
horror characters Bride of Frankenstein
um and I just don't imagine I'm the only
person out there yeah no like especially
when it comes to like comic book stuff
like we're really kind of out of the
loop because we don't watch any of those
movies we don't know anything about
Marvel DC so if you're gonna dress first
as someone from that I have no idea who
you are also dresses whatever you want
just like could you write it in the
caption or like give a a reference to it
100 you know normalize putting what you
are in the capture like in some ver in
some way 100 that I think is important
admin person then we have Olivia Rodrigo
as Betty Boop cute like really I don't
think I don't know anyone who's done
that like that's cute yeah it is a cute
idea I don't know if the execution was
my favorite that's what I would say I
wouldn't have ever guessed she was Betty
Boop and I know Betty Boop right I I
went to school with Betty Boop Betty
Boop and I are close personal friends
right
then we have Kylie as the Bride of
Frankenstein she looks amazing yeah and
now I'm glad to know what she was but
did you know it immediately no okay okay
I never even saw Frankenstein like I'm
not into it's from 1935 the movie no but
like I would know Frankenstein even
though I've never seen the movie true so
true she needed a Frankenstein companion
Travis Travis then we have Kendall
Jenner as sexy Jesse from Toy Story this
was like so basic I was shocked like I
kind of love that she gave it obviously
like no effort because it's like cool
girls like don't care but like wow this
was really like generic okay I feel like
I loved I like I think she looks amazing
she looks amazing um and I kind of like
that it's just like a normal costume and
she clearly like could go to a party and
she's like I'm just gonna be like a kid
bloody Toy Story a kid's costume with
athless chaps yeah yeah yeah like you
know she looked amazing I loved the no
energy yeah no there was energy put
towards those assless chaps no I know
but like when you look at like how long
it probably took her to get ready versus
Kim yeah no but I'm the thing is I'm
sure it's still probably took a long
time to get ready like with Glam and
everything yeah she's giving Prince
Margo as Princess Anna she looks great
yeah Megan Fox and MGK were Pamela
Anderson and Tommy Lee so the pam pam
pam Anderson costume was like this
year's like basic [ __ ] every she looks
like every other [ __ ] like every girl
who's like skinny and has big boobs did
Pamela Anderson like it was if you
executed a well it was cute but like
most people just put on like
corset and blonde wig and like walked
out of the house if anyone can do it
it's MGK and Megan Fox and they did it
really well but just like what I
wouldn't have expected I couldn't have
guessed like this was going to be like
the basic costume that everyone went
with
um so like them choosing that makes it
like a little less cool and original but
there were the they were the best ones
to do it yes best executed yeah I think
it's a great costume and it's topical
timely that's why I think it like
everyone popped off yeah it's all of the
things that but then it makes you think
Kim was Pam Anderson like three years
ago with Jonathan at the end of her time
yeah ahead of her time
Haley Bieber as a model from the Yves
Saint Laurent hot Couture spring 1999
show it's not because I didn't know that
when you saw it like you just you
obviously don't know fashion it's this
is not a costume but I love Haley Bieber
but it's just simply not a costume
yeah it's an outfit inspired by fashion
which is
genuinely what every outfit is and so
when you're a celebrity and you decide
what you want to be for Halloween do you
have to decide it in July so that you
can have like a custom dressmaker like
make this maybe not July well depending
on what it is but I think like you need
a couple of weeks like Kendall wants to
be
Toy Story so she needs that shirt made
like someone like that shirt yeah yeah I
don't think they don't tell that it's
Spirit Halloween but it's very Jesse
they also don't sell it at no it's
custard Outdoors but out of the July
like I think you need a couple of weeks
to make a shirt like that and Haley how
maybe a bit more time which is crazy
because it's on a costume I mean I'll
just stand by like dressing as a model
for my fashion like it's not a costume
yeah no simply and I just want proof
that people went somewhere in these
costumes that's what I'm asking for now
too I just want a reference in the
caption and that you went somewhere well
because the big ones like it's just a
waste of time money and resources the
big Halloween party in La is a costume
Migos party every year and I saw a bunch
of people there but I didn't see any of
the people we discussed in this article
at that party yeah Kim went out though
that was good to see but she's
interested in a costume party right but
I think she went to a costume party
after because Diddy was there got it did
she dress as anything else yet this year
I just want to say like having a
birthday party on Halloween that's not
costume is like extremely just it's
annoying for other people you know
actually not to like be like in like a
name dropper but if you're in my book
you know like on Halloween a few years
ago I went to Seth MacFarlane's birthday
party and it wasn't a costume party so
there was like one or two people there
in costumes that felt so stupid and it's
like I kept my costume in the car but
like it is annoying and inconsiderate
yeah because we're not sitting at your
party the whole time like we're gonna
party hop and so we need to get in and
out of our costumes because you don't
want it to be a costume party make your
birthday another weekend right and like
for you it was just like pink lady like
for Kim it was a whole right it wasn't
even just laugh out in the car no it
wasn't even an elaborate thing yeah yeah
totally next we have North Saint Chicago
and some West as Elias Snoop Dogg
uh Sade and easy I think it's Aaliyah
um yeah I think I bought [ __ ] cute
really cute kids be killing it like
that's a costume Haley take note
next we have Brooklyn Beckham and Nicola
Peltz as Romeo and Juliet doing the
absolute least no it's cute she's doing
nothing oh
he wore a night's sure sorry I didn't
see that that's not a costume they're
not wearing actually any clothing that's
she's not wearing a costume like that's
like when you show up in whatever you're
meant to wear and then like let's say
we're
Romeo and Juliet you know right they
unless was a famous couple throughout
history party like what is it well then
that does change everything was it a
famous couple throughout history party
like nothing about this what to me is
that she's Juliet
no I mean she does kind of look like
Claire Danes in that movie where she
plays Juliet but still like no
coincidence coincidence yeah next Ashley
Graham is a Y2K angel
that's like one of those costumes when
people pull out a costume just like make
some [ __ ] up no look I have a lot of Y2K
things in my closet like maybe I'll be
like a wide 2K Angel no I have a Y2K
into my class and a pair of angel wings
right yeah not a costume not a costume
people like always do like stuff like
that like they'll be like a fairy who
likes dubstep right the dubstep fairy
foreign
it's so stupid like it's so dumb she
looks great but why couldn't she just be
Y2K girly right Y2K by 2K literally
literally this next costume might be my
favorite okay JoJo siwa as Draco Malfoy
so she had um like cut and bleached her
hair a few days ago I was making tick
tocks as Draco so I didn't think that
she would be Draco Malfoy because she
had like kind of spoiled it on Tick Tock
but she was and it was excellent like
actually a costume where you like do a
double take thinking that the person
actually is the person they're dressed
up as is a successful costume and she
looks great great and she made amazing
tick tocks yeah Vanessa Hudgens has
Black Swan Vanessa Hudgens like does
always kill she's like one of those
girls who like does the party circuits
and like always looks good this is like
fine yeah that's okay like it's a
totally
fine costume fine costume like and I
don't need every costume to break the
internet to blow me away yeah except she
was the one who did
um A Star is Born no that was Nina
Dobrev and that was like one of the most
embarrassing moments on the planet when
she was dressed up as a baby who was
also a star because the star was being
born I actually saw a picture like
campaigning for an Oscar I saw a picture
of that recently and it was like
reminding me of how embarrassing that
was to be a human being alive during
that time it was horrifying really truly
costly positively Gosling next Sarah
Michelle Geller's tribute to do Revenge
which is the movie that she was in oh
she said that uh she told the director
she was jealous she never got to wear
the costumes designed for the Rosehill
uniform and so she got one for her
Halloween costume that's like really
cute even though the movie was hella
problematic but cute yeah cute I'm
surprised more people weren't that it
wasn't like that culty of a following
like it was just like a movie people
liked for a minute but that's the thing
about like Netflix movies like will
anything be super culty when it's just
an assembly line of flash in the pants
yeah no it's actually like Netflix has
like shifted the way in which we like
care about [ __ ] yeah because we care
about it for 45 seconds yeah I feel like
only TV shows really can be culty now
yeah that's a good point they keep
coming back right and it used to be like
to be in a movie was like to be in a
real movie and to be in TV was kind of
looked down upon yep speaking of being
in TV Matthew Perry joined Diane Sawyer
for an interview and he shared signs to
look for to indicate that he's relapsed
so I watched his Diane swear thing last
night it was so
heartbreaking like first of all and he's
he's like he's mentioning it all like
nothing is off limits this is clear
because he he visibly looks different he
talks different he's like like the way
he's aging is all because of his
addiction he his teeth like don't like
they're really his huge veneers he's
like everything is like I've had 14
surgeries some of them have been Dental
because of my addiction like so he still
kind of slurs his words his health is
much better but it's like all the
physical implications and
the ramifications of his addiction like
you can see and he tells you like I look
like this I talk like this because of my
addiction and it wasn't like you know a
couple bad years and then he finally got
sober it was like eight bad years and
then like two years sobriety two years
off one year on one year up it's been
Non-Stop and I think a couple years ago
he got to a place where like he thinks
he might you know have
been able to beat it for good and that's
why he's now telling his story
um and the the
takeaway that I had like he's not a
thirsty person he's enormously wealthy
he doesn't need to write a book he
doesn't need to do Diane Sawyer I think
he's so passionate about helping people
like it's so I think he like Longs for I
think he he hopes like hoped that when
he was younger someone like him would
have been out there because you know you
like used to talk about it in the early
2000s talk about addiction so he's so
passionate about helping people
and that's why I don't know if you've
seen there's like a he like Digs at
Keanu Reeves in his book yes and then he
like apologize for it
um and I read something I think it was
on Dumas that was like really poignant
um and it's just like Matthew Perry
hates Keanu Reeves because Keanu Reeves
I think did a movie with River Phoenix
Joaquin Phoenix's brother who passed
away of an overdose and it's like like
holds resentment to Keanu for not like
looking out for River Phoenix or like
doing more to help him because like
that's where Matthew Perry is now he's
like obsessed with helping people like
it's Keanu Reeves he had been an addict
I don't know I don't know enough but
like either he was there while River
Phoenix was struggling or has struggled
himself I'm not sure the entire
background so like it's not just about
like you know actor beef because I don't
think well the vibe that I got from
Matthew Perry after the interview was
like he's like not caught up he doesn't
like he doesn't care about any of this
stuff like he literally was put on life
support he was in a coma for 14 days he
had a two percent chance of living he
was put on like on a respirator with
five other people and that night and
every other person died except for him
like he's not supposed to be here um and
like that's literally all he cares about
now like all he cares about he's such a
pjom and the another takeaway that I got
from the interview is like he's
literally in love with Jennifer Aniston
he talked about her a thousand times
Jenny Jenny Jenny Jenny and it's like
widely known and he talked about when he
first started working on Friends he had
like a huge crush on her and asked her
out she said no
um and she was like of all the people
like everyone the friends like were
really involved and wanted to help him
but like she checked in on him the most
and like they have like a special
connection it was like really cute like
I ship them hard but it's so sad like
his addiction took so much room like he
never got married he never had kids like
he's 55 he looks much older and he's
like just now starting like he wants to
get married he wants to catch up now and
honestly the king needs to marry
Jennifer Aniston oh he needs to marry
Jennifer Aniston like I think that's how
the story ends well his book comes out
this week and I stated that you will
definitely be reading it well I sat down
to read it over the weekend there's been
so much hoopla Fanfare and my Kindle
lick wasn't working and it was just like
pissing me off and then I realized my
Kindle's working fine the book isn't out
yet so that's that on that I feel like
after watching Diane Sawyer and all the
Press I feel like I know every it's only
250 Pages like I feel like I know
everything I feel like you probably
don't though because I don't think that
he would give it all up you know and
also there even though he seems to be
like incredibly authentic he's not gonna
like click bait click here read the book
but there are probably PR people in the
room who do need to sell a book and so
they'll make sure that he's not saying
anything to Diane that gives too much
away yeah yeah Diane did a good job I
feel like you know there's a lot of
interviews that Diane has done like over
her long career that like have come back
to didn't age poorly
um and I think now whenever she does an
interview she's like very
um conscious of that and she did a very
good job like I think he felt
comfortable he's like he was just it was
poorly
stuff she says to like Lindsay Lohan
like a lot of [ __ ] that that like when
we watch like Britney Spears type stuff
right Britney Spears that's that's the
one oh okay
um and that happens with everyone like
David Letterman being disgusting to
everyone so Diane Sawyer is not unique
in that but I think you know she's being
very conscious of her Legacy here on out
understood well [ __ ] lives forever he
shared on the program that if he says
I'm just going to chill at home alone
tonight if he ever says I'm cured that
that would reveal that he has relapsed
yeah said um he talks about his struggle
with addiction of course and told the
journalist that he did all sorts of
things to satiate his addiction over the
years including perusing people's
medicine cabinets at open house throwing
open houses to acquire Vicodin to
maintain his 55 pill per day habit and
he said I think they thought well
there's no way that Chandler came in
right from us yeah no it was when he was
talking about like the height of his
addiction taking 55 Vicodin a day it was
so crazy and he did and I feel like I've
said this a lot about his weight on the
show so he talks about that because he
really struggled with alcohol too and
he's like when I'm fat it's the alcohol
when I'm skinny it's the pills so like
that's why there's such Stark changes
and then towards the end of the show
like when he gets married to Monica like
the last maybe season and I have two
seasons he is living in a treatment
facility and he's being driven to work
in like a treatment facility van every
day and that's why towards the end I
never even realized that he looks so
healthy and that's not like the
beginning of his sobriety forever
because he relapses many many times and
then he ends up in the hospital his
digestive system completely shuts down
and that's what puts him in a coma for
14 days
um but you really can track everything
on friends and he doesn't watch the show
he's like really never seen it
um and so Diane had him watch a couple
moments some of the moments from when he
is clearly struggling and some of the
moments from when he's clearly healthy
and he's like so upset like by the
footage of him like not looking well and
then when he sees the scene where he
marries Monica where he's literally
living in like a sober living facility
he's like so happy he's such a pee Jam
like he's so cute and sweet and honestly
we just we have to protect Matthew Perry
at all costs that was my takeaway as a
friend's fanatic what was your thoughts
on Matthew Perry Chandler before all of
this nothing and that's what Diane
Sawyer says she's like you would never
know like every joke you're brilliant
like every joke lands you don't what was
he one of your favorites one of your
least favorites
um not one of my favorites not one of my
least favorites like very mid probably
spot you know three or four seven six
six yeah if I had to go in order
it would be Phoebe and then it would be
Ross oh it used to be Ross first was it
maybe it would be Ross actually Ross and
Phoebe interchanged one and two
then it would be Chandler and then it
would be Monica and then it would be
Joey and then it would be [ __ ] Rachel
wow it used to be
who was last um Monica
used to hate not like I don't know if
she was like Soldier I guess but used to
hate Monica the older I get the more I
understand mommy used to tell me tell me
I'm a Monica no the more the older I get
the more I understand Monica and the
more like Rachel is just like a [ __ ]
pick me girl who like expects everything
to she's so spoiled like everything just
like happens for her that's not how it
works in the real world like Monica was
chubby in her youth like she is grit you
know she has she's been through tenacity
so I I think that's the beauty of the
show it's like you really can relate to
different people throughout at different
times in your life and that's what
Sawyer Diane Kama Diane was saying she
was like you know what's so crazy is
during covid like the show had a
Renaissance of Renaissance
um
97 billion minutes were consumed to
friends in 2022. that's amazing I just
want to say this new metric of I know
it's a Netflix thing of counting
streaming time in minutes like isn't
working for me yeah tell me nobody
watches your show without telling me
nobody watches your show yeah like
that's how Netflix uh they do their
ratings now like how TV ratings are like
0.14 of this which is so many other
people to do just how many people like I
would even do started the show and then
also just let us know how many people
started show how many people finish the
show yeah no like how many people watch
a show question mark it's not that hard
like we do a YouTube video and they're
able to count views they don't do minute
stream even though some people don't
finish it like 100
um I'm rejecting this metric I because I
have a brother I reject the metric along
with you no idea what it means that 97
million minutes were streamed yeah no
billion billion yeah no that's a good
same thing that's a good call because
okay how many minutes is the entire show
so divide 97 right and divide by that
that's how many people watching it in
its entirety but like you do the math
and then some people watch it like
multiple times so it's like I could have
been responsible for a billion of those
you know right it's not working it's not
working
um and as we get further into the
streaming age like that's gonna have to
be corrected immediately the interview
was on Hulu speaking of streaming so you
can still watch it that's why I watched
it last night I'm totally gonna read his
book and he's really like we must as a
society like we must protect him okay at
all costs he was so cute
well thank you for watching and updating
us it was so good like I loved it I
wanted it to be longer and I want to see
more of his house like and also like I
wanted like obviously like I wanted to
talk to him about addiction but I also
just like his
career is like insane he like decided to
be an actor he was always like funny oh
also I was crazy he's like he's been
like an alcoholic since he was 14 since
the first drink he ever had like wow and
he grew up like his mom was press
secretary for Trudeau's dad who was also
Trudeau prime minister his dad was like
a a big actor on sitcoms he was like
this Golden Child so it's not like you
know addiction is like you come from a
dark past it's like it can happen to
anyone he literally had like a Charmed
Life in Canada moved to America like
auditioned and just you know got a role
on the biggest show ever yeah oh what I
found to be most interesting that um
Chandler he's so funny Matthew Perry
so I mean we weren't really alive like
when friends was airing like we weren't
conscious of what was going on in the
world so apparently when the first
season aired like David Schwimmer was
like the it boy like he was the first
one who got a role in a movie and he was
like the biggest star of all the stars
and after the first season everyone's
contract was up for renegotiation and
David Schwimmer was like we should do it
as a team and Matthew Perry literally
says in to Diane Sawyer interview he's
like fine idiot like oh sure like you're
having right and that's really why they
were so successful was because they all
got paid the same it was an ensemble
show no one was you know more of a star
than the next and even though David
Schwimmer in the beginning like I guess
was the most famous One it constantly
shifted like right then Matthew Perry
was on the number one show and had the
number one movie which is something only
him and someone else have done
I forgot who but he was like had the
number one movie in theaters and the
number one TV show on TV
um
no Matthew Perry Oh Oh someone else in
the world in the world has done yeah so
it was like it was really impressive and
it was constantly shifting but the fact
that they always maintained that they
were equals is why one they ended up
becoming the highest paid actors on Two
And on television and two why they were
so successful 100 it was really smart
and it all started with David Schwimmer
so I feel like David Schwimmer gets like
a rep now for being like kind of like a
dick
um but it was him who who decided that
they all should stay a team amongst
other things it's probably the biggest
factor in why the show was so successful
because we see all the time
it when people get success so quickly
like then they start to resent the show
we saw that with Jeanette McCurdy right
right not getting paid the same amount
but also the difference with that and
what's that Carly it's not an ensemble
show right but this was an ensemble show
and yes like when it first launched some
people were more well received but they
didn't let that change the Dynamics and
then it constantly shifted Jennifer
Aniston became you know like everyone
had their own moments yeah wow it was
really interesting if you like friends
like I I recommend it and if you're like
into like
not into but like if you're curious
about like addiction yeah he speaks
about it very poignantly like you don't
have a choice
so like when he was like I was in a
rehab facility I was leaving after like
90 days after one I think he's been in
rehab like six times maybe more he was
like his therapist was like don't forget
like this isn't your fault and he was
like what he said what do you mean like
I have free will he's like no you
actually don't like in a scenario like
this and he was just really well spoken
about it and I I loved it loved loved
great are you ready for our next story
if it's the next story that's sponsored
by modern fertility yes we've always
been big fans of planning ahead
scheduling trips months in advance
plotting out our next career moves
figuring out what we're doing for dinner
while we still eat breakfast but if
you've never thought much about planning
for kids modern fertility might be the
product Trio so modern fertility was
created it's an easy and affordable way
to test your fertility hormones at home
with a simple finger prick you can mail
it in with a prepaid label and you will
get personalized results within six
business days here are some of the
insights that you'll get you'll get
insights into your hormone levels like
your ovarian reserve which is basically
if you have more fewer eggs than the
average woman your age they also have
other important factors that can impact
your fertility the results are going to
go deep into what every hormone means
and you can also download the results to
review with your doctor for next steps
traditional hormone testing at a
fertility clinic can cost over six
hundred dollars but modern fertility
tests the same general set of hormones
at a fraction of the price and if you go
to modernfertility.com toast30 you can
get 30 off your test plus you can get
reimbursed for the test through your FSA
or HSA if you want kids today or maybe
one day in the future clinically sound
information about your body can help
make the decision that's right for you
right now modern fertility is offering
our listeners thirty dollars off the
test when you go to modernfertility.com
toast30 that's a limited time offer of
thirty dollars off which means your
tests will come at just 149 which is
kind of crazy because hormone testing is
at a fertility clinic can cost more than
three times as much get 30 off your
fertility test when you go to
modernfertility.com toast30
modernfertility.com t-o-a-s-t-30
toast 30 is that link again
modernfertility.com toast 30. greatness
thank you so much
Missy viserys our next story I forgot
we're in me too and I can't forget my
wig is so [ __ ] itchy and my
crown is slipping oh maybe it says ahead
maybe it's a sign that you're really not
prepared for it give it to me
Crown okay let's see how it looks on you
my widow's peak is gonna look stunning
Elvis Harris
like my [ __ ] Crown it literally feels
right it looks nice it looks good on you
the people of Westeros deserve this one
as Prince with uh rhaenyra's Queen you
look good the people of Westeros they
don't look good
to all my subjects I love you dearly
especially the city watch oh this is
like a crazy ass Crown yeah
it really is it's heavy is the mind of
its own
okay our next story some lovely wedding
news we had two Bachelor people get
married this weekend one is a entirely
Bachelor couple Astrid lock and Kevin
gwent got married one year after
welcoming their son they fell in love on
Bachelor in Paradise and had this baby
last year and now they got married it
was a bachelor studded affair with
Rachel Lindsay Blake Horseman Alexis
Waters Christina Shulman and Whitney
Whitney Franz way I haven't heard so
many of those names in so long like and
Christina gianina
uh Blake and Jenny and are still
together still together and for
Halloween they dressed as each other on
each other's shows so she was Blake
sweating and crying when Becca broke up
with him and he was her running in that
wedding dress he wore the actual wedding
dress from the show looks so thirsty I
can't like I really can't talk about it
um Let's Talk About Kevin and Astrid I
think they're such a great couple and
I'm like so glad that they stood the
test of time I don't think about them
often but every time I do I just check
in I'm like are they still together I
don't keep up with Bachelor anymore like
I don't really care but like this these
two that came out of it like I love it I
love it I love it so much and it really
goes to show I feel like so many people
on The Bachelor like they don't get
together they don't stay together
because like we live so far apart right
they're so different and he's living in
another country he lived in another
country and she's in Tampa they're
making it work they're making it work
yeah what's your excuse you know
literally what's your excuse no they're
so cute I love them I think that was a
great season of Bachelor in Paradise it
was but the only thing that's a shame is
that they ended
the season like Asher and Kevin weren't
together because they thought that they
couldn't make it work like they broke up
like really randomly didn't see their
engagement no and then they got back
together in real life like a few weeks
later and so it's like just not a
perfect season because they don't ride
off into the sunset together
she's cooking some chicken it smells
good it's just a phantom smell because
I'm hungry no I definitely smell some
things I know someone's cooking out my
chicken from last night and if they eat
my chicken I'll be so mad because like
that's what I wanted for lunch that's
all
I'm gonna take this [ __ ] sword we
have extra schnitzel though I know but
like the one from last time it's
probably not your schnitzel but it could
be it smells really good it does smell
good oh no it actually smells like
there's veggies being cooked oh then
it's definitely not mine
um and also another bachelor wedding was
this weekend so if you weren't at one
you were hopefully at the other Maddie
Pruitt got married in Dallas shout out
Adam gotchalk for the premium content
Instagram and Raven I felt like I was
there then also Hannah Ann was there
Kelly Flanagan Victoria Fuller Kelly
Flanagan is dating pilot Pete although
maybe she wasn't given a plus one or
maybe Maddie didn't want her
ex-boyfriend at her wedding
um maybe both yeah she's only dating no
ring no bring so Maddie and this guy
have been together I think they were
dating for three months before they got
engaged or or they were dating sorry
they they were engaged for three months
yes that's it okay they've only been
engaged for three months and I think a
lot of that has to do with the fact that
they're deeply religious and they did
not consummate until after the wedding
so you know girls got to do what she's
got to do she looks beautiful people
um people have really started to [ __ ]
hate Maddie it because she's like uh on
Tick Tock at least she went viral I feel
like she's always viral no but so she
became um she's like a motivational
speaker she's a pastor like a like she's
like a youth leader youth group she's
not a pastor but she speaks she has I
don't know
she doesn't do sermons but she but she
gets on stage and preaches yes yes at
like these big churches that have like
videos she wears like a little Ted Talk
microphone it's at a church or like a
convention I think it's a church I think
it's like a mega church okay so this um
path this sermon she gave like went
viral because she said Jesus is the only
one who can satisfy and then like
everyone was like oh you're terrify this
you know
um and she's just like really religious
and so I feel like just people like hate
religious people so I kind of feel bad
for her um because she's a nice girl her
engagement and the whole thing is like
definitely you know
fast but they seem to be in love and
they had Stunning Weddings stunning it
looks like she trimmed her hair I think
it's all so nice like first of all she
was always that religious on the show
like people didn't like Peter wanted to
pretend like he could change her and
like she literally had to leave him
because he wasn't like the man of faith
that she was looking for she's very
principal she's so principled I feel
like she found the right person for her
and she's like why wait yeah let's get
married who said you have to wait to be
engaged for a year like people used to
like literally meet and get married
within six months yeah so no I think
she's sweet like I
it's obviously not
how I would do it but that's because I'm
not adding and I'm not Catholic yeah but
like you got married young I did I did
well I don't think they're young I think
she is young she was she's 26 now but
like she was like 23 on her season I
mean it's not that young to get married
especially if you're a virgin 26. I got
married 17.
um especially if you're a virgin like
yeah all the power to you like I hope
they stay together just to prove
everyone wrong like everyone's just so
negative because he's like a little
cringe she's like hey girl like is he's
like okay it's intonations and like he's
like a little weird but I'm not in it
enough to have seen negativity I don't
think
we see like when they got engaged and
the highlights and obviously I'm not on
Tick Tock and sometimes I have seen her
reels of her
speaking engagement yeah but I don't
like read the comments so I don't know
no no but like they went viral on Tick
Tock but she's also like so viral in the
other like it swings both ways like she
has so many followers from the show yeah
she's a big influencer no and she did a
good job transition she's very Niche
like she's very Southern she's very
religious like and she thrives in that
digital Community right I think she's
like living her best life and maybe
that's not for everyone who out there
but she seems really happy yeah no she
looked beautiful the wedding was
beautiful it was at his family's house
it was a beautiful house beautiful
wedding oh gorgeous yeah really gorgeous
really really gorgeous he's um he's an
heir
and air not the spare no he's an heir to
a billion dollar Fortune yeah I'm not
sure what from but gotta look into it
very nice so for that love that for her
yeah get a girl get a girl our next
story um no we have two more stories
with little Tech news okay first of all
Instagram is down right yeah what the
[ __ ] and users are reporting their
accounts are being suspended and people
are losing followers amid the mystery
outage but you don't even you might be
losing followers from people's accounts
being suspended right so like I wanted
to see if I lost followers but like
honestly I don't even want to go look
because apparently if you open Instagram
and you close it your account will get
suspended so I'm not even opening the
app oh well I opened it but then I did
and then I heard about this so I closed
it yeah yeah and when I haven't opened
it since but I want to see it if I'm
losing followers or anything interesting
Instagram is like constantly [ __ ] up
and they really need to get their
[ __ ] [ __ ] together like and they're
like you want to be the number one
platform meta you want to be at all well
that comes with responsibility they also
led to Gaslight because people are
reporting This and like enough for it to
be like we heard about it this morning
it's already like a news story issue
Instagram Tweets we're aware that some
of you are having issues accessing your
Instagram account we're looking into it
and apologize for the inconvenience
gaslighter yeah like not just like hey
shit's crazy over here we're working on
it just like stay tuned yeah no that's
so true like the way in which they like
minimize it in their statement yeah
totally but it's like we we all know
yeah no it's really [ __ ] annoying
like my um
but this is how most people whatever
business you're in like a lot of
people's businesses reply rely on
Instagram and they're like always
[ __ ] up yeah but it's also crazy when
Instagram goes down and like people
realize like what a Reliance they have
on it aside from like if it's your
business but
um and people like getting so pressed
that they're losing followers it's like
also maybe we should touch get some
perspective touch grass as Claudia would
say no for sure but like it is a weekday
like P this is people's livelihood like
get it together maybe it's a spooky
outage for Halloween
perhaps brother is that how you feel
when Instagram goes down like for you
yeah no it's like we literally run a
business and Instagram is a huge part of
that like [ __ ] off yeah
it's annoying at least we could sell
podcast right so if you guys don't hear
from us on Instagram today we're over
here podcasting yeah totally totally our
fifth and final story is some hilarious
news that's brought to you by liquid IV
oh yeah liquid Ivy loves comedy Cooler
weather makes it easy to miss signs of
dehydration like overheating or
perspiration which means it's even more
important to keep your body hydrated
liquid IV fuels your well-being with
easy ways to stay hydrated in just one
stick you're getting five essential
vitamins and hydrating two times faster
than you would with water alone
so liquid IV is a fabulous product it is
if you have a hard time drinking water
whether it's hot cold like you just
forget and just don't like the taste
hello that's me liquidity is fabulous
because you put a stick in a bottle of
water and it makes the bottle of water
two to three times more hydrating so
you're just like being more efficient
and it changes the flavor because I
think water tastes disgusting but
liquidity comes in so many different
flavors and you'll find one that you
really really like and then it's like
you're drinking something more fun you
know like a delicious juice not a
disgusting water juice so one stick of
liquid IV into 16 ounces of water will
hydrate you two times faster and more
efficiently than water alone and that
little stick contains five essential
vitamins B3 B5 B6 B12 and vitamin C it
has three times the electrolytes of a
traditional sports drink which means
it's a great thing to drink yes when
you're dehydrated also when you're
hungover it's truly miraculous right
before bed there's nothing like it
um it's also made with premium
ingredients it's non-GMO and it's free
from gluten it's free from dairy it is
free from soy they're also on a mission
to change the world to date liquid IV is
donated needed over 25 million servings
in over 50 countries around the world
which is fabulous because you can spend
money on liquid IV knowing that that
money is going to help really important
causes grab your liquid IV in bulk
nationwide at Costco or get 15 off when
you go to liquid iv.com toast that's 15
off anything you order on their site
when you shop better hydration today at
liquid IV l i q u i d iv.com toast
t-o-a-s-t liquid ib.com
toast thank you so much I love being
hydrated that way I don't have to say
Juliana I drink a lot of water Juliana I
drink a lot of liquid IV
um can you like my Johnson I would love
to let your Johnson our fit and final
story is literally the funniest news
I've ever seen it is hilarious
pranksters posing as laid off Twitter
employees trick media Outlets so a pair
of pranksters posing as laid off Twitter
employees tricked multiple media outlets
on Friday as the public anxiously
awaited news on whether Elon Musk had
begun fun axing staffers so cnbc's
Deirdre Bosa interview he's so
embarrassing for Deirdre because she's
really like the one who's getting
dragged he interviewed two people who
identified themselves as Twitter
employees and we're seeing near the
company's San Francisco headquarters
carrying cardboard boxes so these guys
the two men said they were named Raul
ligma and Daniel Johnson so we have
ligma Johnson who's laid off there
walking outside of Twitter headquarters
just Kevin dressed like classic Silicon
Valley Engineers like everything they're
wearing is Patagonia like the backpack
it's so funny and so like I guess nobody
thought to like
check if they were real employees they
just like took advantage of the fact
that the media was waiting outside
Twitter headquarters like sharks like
eating up whatever was going to happen
so they stood out there with cardboard
boxes and was like yeah I got laid off
I've been a software engineer here for
six years like they were just making
[ __ ] up they were like I'm really
worried about how I'm gonna you know
make my car payments actually have a
Tesla I love Elon it was so funny and
they were just like trolling the media
and like the way that like it's actually
crazy how like you would be a reporter
and not even verify that these people
worked right at Twitter right it's like
at the end of the day it's like a funny
thing but also it's like a statement I'm
like how embarrassing it is to be a
journalist it reminds me of the Manti
Teo documentary where those guys who
Unearthed that the girlfriend was fake
were trying to make a statement about
media how like they could just keep
saying the same story over and over
again without even looking into it one
iota it obviously turned into something
other than that but it's so true yeah no
it's like it's really embarrassing for
everyone who was like caught you know
the the TV cameras doing interviews with
these guys the guy and they don't even
realize they're being trolled the guy's
like all right I really gotta go I got
to talk to my husband and wife about
this like husband and wife like nobody
even blinks and they weren't the funny
thing is like the concept of what they
did was really funny I didn't think in
the interviews they were being that
they're being like crazy pranksters it
was like this was just the prank and and
really nothing more
um Elon tweeted about it he thought it
was funny he thought it was funny he
said that ligma Johnson had it coming he
had it coming with an eggplant emoji and
a sweater water anyways the CNBC
reporter tweeted it's happening entire
team of data Engineers let go these are
two of them she said they are visibly
shaken Daniel tells us Daniel tells us
he owns a Tesla and doesn't know how
he's going to make payments on his Tesla
no the visibly shaken is so embarrassing
for you so embarrassing but then I went
to dear's profile because I was like has
she corrected this because the Tweet is
still up and this is what she she quote
tweeted herself and said earlier today
we reported on CNBC that a team of data
Engineers was let go at Twitter based on
the account of two people who told us
they were part of that team we have not
been able to confirm that they were
actual employees or that the CEO has
laid anyone off today oh my God not her
like literally not correcting it
literally we were unable to confirm well
you never tried right and she said
confusion Reigns outside Twitter HQ are
people being let go are they trolling
the media no the questions have been
answered they are trolling the media no
that's so crazy to like get trolled it's
like so embarrassing but then to not own
it like or like delete the Tweet like
this is misinformation no you honestly
if you're not if you're spreading
misinformation like you can't delete it
as a reporter you have to like follow up
with a correction you can't just remove
the article you know right no it's like
the lack of journalistic Integrity in
this country it's giving muckraker it's
giving muckers journalism like and these
guys are like on Twitter now you know
like laughing about it so it's like
confirmed it's a confirmed prank
um Daily Mail got pranked hard because
they were like ligma left Johnson right
or two software Engineers is it's so
[ __ ] funny like so funny and it's
it's literally like a perfect prank
because these guys like I don't think
they want it to be famous like they just
thought it was funny like they just they
didn't really have like an agenda or
anything they just wanted to be funny
yeah and it succeeded it's funny and
it's a good prank it really is so
that's what she needed to know those
were the past five years just a reminder
to ligma Johnson
that's kind of like my key takeaway
always like constantly be ligma in
Johnson's you know yeah like my Johnson
yeah today that's what I say to your
daughter
I say hey Rainier get over here ligma
Johnson
yeah
it's not gonna work for me yeah right
near a Liggett
lick it good good so this has been toast
to be in 2022 it's been an honor having
King viserys the useless on my podcast
today the number one podcast in all of
Westeros uh to my millions of fans thank
you actually before we go viserys I had
uh our listeners submit questions for
you are you open to doing some sort of
Spirited Town Hall debate of course
brother I'm an open book all right let
me grab the questions
this one comes from
Daniel Johnson
viserys
you suck ligma Johnson
well Daniel I would say bring your
Johnson to me and we shall see
this next one is coming from a Raul
ligma
says viserys you suck ligma Johnson
another Johnson I'd love to leg
[Laughter]
um and this tweet is from a Deirdre she
says viserys what you plan to do about
all the employees being fired from
Twitter
I would say Deidra Deidra darling
Deirdre dear Deirdre do your job
dear draw Deirdre
do your job
oh my God you my favorite day of the
year like to be with you is toaster and
you're so really like not okay no for
sure but like visceros is really like a
peaceful energy yeah and it's been hard
for me to like be combative I have to no
and like I need to I'm never the
combative one like was Ryan comative
watch the clips roll the tape Ryan was
extremely combative in in his ineptitude
you know
no like for viserys like I had to really
Tamp down some of like my inner energy
rubber energy because I'm visceros the
peaceful you've been anxiously but I
don't know how to achieve it and I just
want your daughter to ligma Johnson
and you've been extremely not peaceful
no I've been extremely disgusting but
that's called playing a character Jackie
like it's character acting you should
know like you're a character actor first
that's for sure so I gotta go home so I
can rail your daughter
um I don't know what she's speaking to
you right now we all saw the joke no she
understood that's something we do all
the time it wasn't like a sign yeah
we're just playing like I stab her she
stabs me we have a lot of fun sounds
like a great time it is you should come
to Dragonstone one time brother I'll
show you how it's done
I'll let you ligma Johnson
you guys hope you enjoyed thank you so
much I cannot wait to do the toast
tomorrow not in a wig I've never been so
[ __ ] itchy my whole life
um thank you so much for listening to
the the toast the number one morning
show in Westeros where we discuss where
we deliver the fast five stories that
you need to show everybody through
Friday and YouTube so if you're watching
this on YouTube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
Spotify iTunes did your public radio I
have radiocast box all the places
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the toes leave if I saw review about how
wickedly talented we are hope you guys
have an amazing Monday happy Halloween
we'll see you tomorrow Happy Halloween
everyone trick or treat ligma Johnson
and don't forget to leg my Johnson
foreign